Ils auraient pu faire parti du F.B.I.
Ils auraient pu faire parti de la C.I.A.
Ils auraient pu faire parti du G.I.G.N.
Mais ils ont raté le concours.
Ils sont agents de surveillance... de la voie publique.
Il allait un peu vite lui.
Ouais.
Ils font régner l'ordre.
C'est un cinq ou un S ?
C'est un cinq ! C'est un cinq !
Ils veillent sur la ville.
À leur manière.
Ils prennent des risques démesurés.
Ils sont les meilleurs et font partis de l'élite.
Réputés pour ne jamais rien laisser passer...
Ils n'en sont pas moins dépourvus d'un grand coeur.
Viens là toi ! Viens ! Viens ici !
C'est votre voiture ça, monsieur ?
Ouais.
Vous êtes au courant qu'on est le 16 du mois ?
Et alors ?
Le stationnement est autorisé du côté pair entre le 16 et le 31 du mois.
Vous êtes garé au numéro treize de la rue, monsieur.
On va devoir vous verbaliser, ça fera 22 euros.
Quoi ?
Non mais ça fait même pas deux minutes que je suis garé là, enfin...
C'est pas notre problème ça monsieur...
Attendez, qu'est-ce que je vois là ?
Vous êtes sur une place handicapée ?
Hein ?
Non... non mais...
Ah bah si.
Pourtant, je vois pas le petit macaron.
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe, vous avez pas vu le marquage au sol, c'est ça ?
Non mais j'ai pas fait gaffe, j'étais un peu pressé, j'avais un truc à faire là...
Ça fera 135 euros.
170 euros, exactement,
parce que je viens de voir que monsieur est aussi sur une place livraison.
Quoi ?
Oh, très juste.
Non mais faut pas abuser, je suis pas sur une place livraison,
j'ai juste une roue qui déborde.
Ça... ça compte pas ça.
Ça compte.
Putain, mais vous jouez à quoi là ?
Vous voulez que je la bute, c'est ça ?
Non, mais ok c'est bon, je vais la payer son amende de merde !
Ah par contre ça c'est pas possible madame.
Quoi ?! Mais n'importe quoi !
Ecoutez, un jour j'ai...
Vous tenez vraiment à ce que je lui tire une balle en pleine tête,
c'est ça que vous voulez ?
C'est ça que vous cherchez, hein ?!
Pas du tout.
Alors pourquoi vous m'alignez comme ça ?!
Parce qu'on ne fait que notre métier, monsieur.
Exactement, que notre métier.
Comment vous vous appelez, monsieur ?
Tony.
Et bien vous savez quoi, Tony ?
On ne fait que notre métier.
Alors calmez-vous maintenant.
Bon, vous voulez continuer à mettre des amendes ?
Allez-y, moi j'ai pas que ça à faire. Allez, viens! Viens, toi !
Non !!
Pervenches de merde !!
le mec il a cligné des deux yeux comme ça, et j'ai pas compris...
Félicitations, messieurs.
Vous avez fait du bon boulot.
On a fait que notre métier, monsieur le préfet.
C'est avec beaucoup d'honneur que je vous fais détective.
De façon à ce que vous puissiez protéger la ville comme elle le mérite.
Nous sommes très honorés, monsieur le préfet.
Mais ça sera non.
Quoi ?
Quels hommes.
Ça c'est des bonhommes, ça.
Bon allez...
Quand un homme et son uniforme ne font qu'un...
Rien, ni personne, ne peut les séparer.
Ils continueront à protéger la ville...
À leur manière.
Un stationnement gênant.